I know when I tell you the following
headline many of you will say is this a
rerun David is this a 2020 episode or a
2021 episode no it is almost October of
2022.
and 61 percent of Republicans
still think that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 presidential election it is
almost October of 2022. Monmouth poll
shows according to NBC news that nearly
a third of all Americans including six
in ten Republicans continue to hold the
debunked belief that President Joe Biden
did not win the 2020 election
legitimately this is a new Monmouth
University poll released the day before
the January 6 committee was going to
hold a hearing because of the hurricane
the January 6 committee has canceled
today's hearing just as an FYI
29 percent of all respondents as well as
61 percent of Republicans say that Joe
Biden won due to voter fraud due to
voter fraud
can you imagine these numbers have been
relatively consistent over time if you
look at the chart you see that late in
2020 and throughout most of 2021 about
32 percent of all Americans believed
Biden won due to voter fraud that is
down just slightly in 2022 to 29
these are incredible numbers that the
world sees and says what the hell is
going on in the United States and they
are right to ask that question
you really
oh how do you share a country
and how do you run a government
split with individuals who believe the
system only works when they win that's
fundamentally what this is you know many
of you wrote to me after my interview
yesterday with Republican candidate
Allison Hayden the interview was a
complete mess complete and total mess
um she's running against Eric swalwell
in California our friend Eric swalwell
who by the way I obviously Support
swalwell over Allison Hayden in that
race in case I didn't make it completely
clear during the interview and people
wrote to me and said you know David an
interesting question to ask folks like
this people like Allison Hayden who say
no no no no if you can't trust the the
election results
would they be flipping out the way
they've been flipping out about voter
fraud and election Integrity since
November of 2020. would they be doing
the same thing if the results had shown
Trump had won because they claim that
their concern is not about who won that
their concern is about the process as I
lose my earpiece here due to excitement
they say the concern is about the
process and the handling of the ballots
and the Integrity of how everything was
handled
would they be behaving the same way if
it had been Donald Trump who had won
Under the exact same circumstances and
of course we all know the answer and
that gets us down to this very again I
know we use this it's like five times a
show we get to this point this is
extraordinarily authoritarian the system
can be trusted when I've won
and when I've lost it is a systemic
problem that we need to fix now there's
probably some imagine a Venn diagram the
people who believe Trump won in 2020 and
the people who believe that Barack Obama
was not really born in the United States
my guess is there's a pretty significant
overlap between those two groups and it
really shows the power of endlessly
repeating a lie
to some degree
some of that 61 percent you and I know
they don't literally believe that Donald
Trump won in November of 2020 but it's a
combination of other things some of the
61 percent that are saying I believe
Trump won
say it because it signals membership in
a team and we've talked about this
before you have to show that you're part
of the team and you show that by saying
Donald Trump actually is the winner of
the 2020 election others have a
cognitive dissonance where they simply
can't admit even to themselves they were
Bamboozled by a very mediocre charlatan
that's what happened and the way that
they avoid admitting that to themselves
is by saying oh the guy actually won the
guy I supported actually is the winner
and so there's a lot of group psychology
at play there's a lot of magical
thinking there's a lot of non-thinking
at Play
but it's all extremely demoralizing when
we say Hey you know we should at least
be able to agree on some basis of fact
here and unfortunately we can't do that
61 percent of Republicans don't believe
Joe Biden won the 2020 election